jean-michel j'aime mieux bonjour bon je
me suis car un juge merci ne recevra
chez vous alors maire sortant de sainte
anne vous avez été élus en 2014 avait 62
ans vous êtes chef d'entreprise et donc
c'était votre votre premier mandat là
qui va s'achever dans quelques semaines
un premier mandat qui a été marqué par
une activité assez intense de votre
opposition municipale dès le début du
mandat
ils vous ont reproché un certain nombre
de choses et on a l'impression quand
même qui ne vous ont pas lâchés tout au
long de ces six ans comment vous avez
vécu tout ça mais ils ne m'ont pas lâché
c'est vrai comment j'ai vécu cela en
tout cas aujourd'hui je suis un homme
heureux heureux parce que malgré toutes
ces propos disgracieux
malgré tous ces comportements j'ai pu
quand même résisté et j'ai pu quand même
faire de cette ville belle grande
économiquement stable à kohat une ville
effectivement qui financièrement est
très stable aussi dense et du bonheur
alors ce que je déplore c'est que les
gens considéraient à l'époque que en
dehors d'eux en tout cas ceux qui ont
perdu que nul ne pouvait gérer cette
sainte anne
j'en ai fait la démonstration avec mon
groupe que nous avons quand même des
capacités les potentialités et la force
pour transformer cette année aujourd'hui
je vois qui les tient effectivement que
le cette année et que la ville rayonne
alors du coup ça vous a même encouragé à
vouloir tenter un deuxième mandat la wii
par sur le travail fait le travail
réalisé
commandez exige que nous soyons de
nouveau là nous avons redressé les
comptes
nous avons aussi créé les conditions
notamment au niveau du personnel du
travail a été fait au niveau aussi de
l'école vous savez toutes les écoles de
sainte anne sont aux normes donc et
aussi vous savez nous avions à l'époque
des personnes de sainte anne qui ne
gagnaient pas le smic
nous avons régularisé d'accord nous
avons personnes delà de la ville des
employés de la ville et abrite ce que
nous avons vu des 200 employés
seat et pourrait dire que c'est beaucoup
mais c'est anne la ville en tout cas
comment la ville l'emploi c'est la ville
parce que nous avons que le club est
tyrannique qui qui créent de l'emploi il
a est le deuxième employeur et bien la
ville de sainte anne
mais c'est des emplois nécessaires si
c'est nécessaire et c'est ce qu'il faut
diviser
et puis vous savez puisque nous n'avons
pas vraiment de structures économiques
fortes sur un talent et de leicester que
l'élan que la ville contribue justement
à mettre au travail dès cette année
alors je disais jean-michel j'ai mieux
plusieurs polémiques durant ce mandat
alors à tort ou à raison mais on vous a
reproché alors l'opposition notamment
avaient peut-être un certain nombre de
sainte-anne et sainte anne est aussi le
déplacement de la statue du neg marrons
l'attribution de la gestion de la pointe
marin aux glénan au lieu d'une
entreprise de martinique
voilà et puis toujours ce ce dialogue
semble-t-il tendues et difficiles avec
avec l'opposition
vous aviez souhaité vous réconcilier les
gars à mal sa après votre élection là en
2014 est ce que c'est le cas justement
je vous parlais l'ancien maire et le
nouveau maire de sainte-anne je dirai un
mot fois je conseille dans ce match com
est un imposteur à un imposteur pour cet
homme est arrivé au pouvoir parce que
jean-michel j'ai mieux et raphaël
bellemans le somme les deux jeunes de
l'époque qui ont tous fait qu'ils sont
au pouvoir en 2001 il a perdu les
élections
mais bon je veux pas qu'on s'attarde de
trous et il ne veut les rencontrer à
gotham karting automne ou n'a souhaité
que je fasse le moins amoureux pour deux
voix et je les fais des manières
aujourd'hui je suis maire de sainte anne
d'accord ce monsieur considère être en
dehors de lui personne le plus chéri
s'étonne qu'on comprenne connaissance
dorénavant que nous avons des
potentialités à sainte anne nous avons
des sommités déjà capable de gérer la
ville de gaillac est légal et le la
réalisation la plus emblématique de
votre mandat qu'est-ce que vous mettriez
comme symbole car vous êtes la
réalisation venue du mal à l'aise parce
que nous avons des réalisations les
quartiers entiers des infra et à nous
deux une ou deux oui vous avez des
écoles qui sont non nous avons enlevé de
la mer puisque nous parlons de deux
villes écologiques d'accord soutient
l'écologiste aujourd'hui à cette haine
c'est bien jean michel jumez le même son
équipe d'accord parce que les écoles ont
été mises à niveau l'amiante est sorti
nous avons aussi balisé la zone de 300
mètres
d'accord nous avons investi au manoir de
brouillard
nous avons réglé la problématique des
employés vous savez ces minutes c'est
trop peu pour voir tout vous dire
alors maintenant on va en venir à votre
élément prioritaire pour le prochain
mandat si vous êtes élu qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiteriez faire
que vous n'avez pas pu faire un an dans
les six ans où que vous voulez continuer
que vous avez entamé un n'a jamais
arrêté d'investir
d'accord on n'a jamais arrêté d'investir
d'accord aujourd'hui un gros
investissement que nous voulons faire
c'est l'achat du manhwa de brega un
million six cent mille euros
l'intérêt pour le victimise de mettre
les jeunes le travail mettre en place
une centre de formation qui permettra
aux jeunes effectivement de ce2 de
pouvoir être formés à l'hôtellerie au
service et que ces textes est extra
ces mêmes manoir nous permettra aussi
et concernant le foncier de votre femme
très et à 5 de foncier d'accord qui
permet de désactiver le quartier
derrière morts nous allons quand même
investir la meilleure parce que vous
savez quand vous allez à partir la ville
mise en service dans cette pièce mais ça
maintient l'ensemble de ses dadas 2010
oui pour aider une petite ville comme
stan qui a effectué un investissement
que je ne possède un hôtel c'est quelque
chose de grave nous avons un gros projet
là un nouveau rejet de chèque pour
mettre les jeunes à l'emploi parce que
nous avons vécu trés d'apprentissage
d'accord est de plus en plus nous
embauchons déjà de cela et nos forces
nous formons les jeunes aussi nous
venons en 2016-17 nous avons quand même
eu cinq personnes ayant une licence
universitaire merci jean michel c'est
venez d'avoir répondu à nos questions
oui oui c'est déjà terminé ça passe très
vite mais vous avez dit beaucoup de
choses
[Rires]